uh senator tom coburn Republican from
Oklahoma of course he does his annual
waste book and this is where he gives
all these examples of ways that the
government is wasting your money this
year it was a hundred examples of what
he called ridiculous government waste
that cost taxpayers a cool thirty
billion dollars let's look at some of
the things that we are wasting dough on
all right so I'm gonna read these quick
and then I'll break down some of the
better ones for you beachfront property
for millionaires five hundred million
dollars a botched blimp cost us three
hundred million NASA's pillow knots cost
us 360,000 the fort hood shooter who's
still on the federal payroll made fifty
three thousand dollars this year NASA
looking for intelligent life in Congress
yes this is real three million dollars
i'm going to give you a better
explanation of that television ads for
hurricane sandy cost 65 million dollars
the Bureau of print and engraving ruined
new hundred-dollar bills that cost us
four million we spruced up a block in a
Kansas town for five hundred thousand
dollars NASA's 3d pizza printer that was
125 k uh we educated Hollywood producers
and writers for 1.5 million and
equipment in Afghanistan cost a seven
billion so I just want to explain a
couple of these real quick so the
botched blimp the army spent over three
years building a football-field-sized
blimp uh which was going to provide
continuous surveillance over Afghanistan
but it was so flawed that they just gave
it up altogether so all the money was
the waste on that one uh NASA looking
for intelligent life in Congress I'm
always looking for intelligent life in
Congress but they literally spent three
million dollars they teamed up with
Georgetown University to host a one-week
seminar to just discuss how Congress
works when you could go to 11th grade
social studies and learn that the
sprucing up of a block in Kansas the
d-o-t awarded a tiny Kansas at town with
a population of 1,100 half a million
dollars to make one block nicer and then
all kinds of this stuff and then the big
one being the seven billion for the
Afghanistan stuff it's just for
equipment and things that we have there
that we're just not going to bring back
here and we don't want to give to them
because we don't trust them so we're
literally just going to junk seven
billion dollars worth of machines and
equipment that we've sent there well the
the Afghanistan thing is just the waste
of war yeah that's and that's a whole
other guy could do a show on the waste
of war and how ever heard that is but
the blimp and you know it probably me
that it was a military endeavor the that
sort of makes sense and what the
government can do well that the private
sector in a capitalist society doesn't
do well is pure art and pure science is
beautification is the development of
ideas that don't necessarily turn a
profit okay so we'll give them the the
Block in Kansas up a unified the lock
against will give imagine doing good for
the people of the country the I mean
that's that's infrastructure right
that's what the government should be
spending money oh yeah I got it I gotta
jump in take care that's why I threw
that one in there I wanted to show that
not all of this what he's putting in
here is is completely pie in the sky
nuttiness should not be trusted okay so
that's so so he should not be trusted uh
the publication that wrote about this
was the Washington Times a publication
that should not be trusted because it is
right wing and i love that a right-wing
publication is talking about government
waste you're talking about government
waste you know i think government waste
is not taxing corporations the
appropriate tax bracket I think that's
government waste right they're getting
all these subsidies and they're paying
less in taxes exactly so so if we really
want to talk about the economy and how
[ __ ] up things are let's focus on the
people that aren't paying their taxes
cuz that's the real issue right and all
this picking on NASA I don't agree with
that either right because Republicans
love to do this [ __ ] okay I know I'm
cussing a lot but it just makes me angry
right when it comes to scientific
research Republicans love love to pick
at it and say oh what a waste what a
waste the whole pillow knots thing
there's a reason why people at NASA
these astronauts in these these
engineers are doing that
I when it comes to space exploration
it's expensive and we need to do space
exploration rights or Republicans have
always hated that basically for this
pillow last thing we were basically
paying people to sort of lay it at
slightly off angles because that would
affect out pure science right and I
think what he would I think what we
would argue is what we don't send people
to the space station even anymore so why
should we be paying for it but I i get
what youre your point is work may they
make it wasn't matter whether we do or
not you know this is the mistake that uh
we tend to make when we look at science
and math and and the arts in the united
states uh you reject basic science basic
science is necessary to understand the
world around sometimes that means doing
an experiment that doesn't prove the
thesis from which he started um there
was a guy running for comfort uh
Congress a few years ago who is big
thing was there spending two and a half
million dollars to study grub warts in
the Louisiana Delta I've never even
heard of a grub wart well okay that that
doesn't mean that they're not some way
valuable to the environment or that they
have there's no reason to study them
right the fact that you never heard of
them Sir is the are these types of
things they're sort of low-hanging fruit
though because also what one of them
what was also they spent a couple
hundred thousand ought to study the
oddity of the duck penis so of course
that's out so of course that sounds
ludicrous but I think you might defend
it yeah I will defend it so they were
talking about how our researchers found
uh you know the reproductive organs of
ducks super interesting turns out that a
duck a male duck has a corkscrew penis
there's a reason for that I don't
remember the specifics but the reason
why that research was done was be like
why they wanna you know w's the penis
why not no but they're doing that to
understand the evolution of these ducks
why did this happen how does this impact
you know the reproduction of other
animals it's fascinating stuff and it's
not just done to know first of all if
you're doing something just to be
enlightened that's fine in and of itself
I would rather spend the money on that
as opposed to on fleeted defense budget
that's my thing yeah yeah so okay so I
want to talk about that part so we sort
of glossed over the seven
just for all this stuff first off we've
been in Afghanistan is the longest war
that we've ever been in we've already
announced we're continuing it to 2020
for a couple weeks ago that somehow got
glossed over by everybody but the idea
that we have all this equipment there
that we won't even trust them to do
anything with so we're literally going
to junk it isn't that like the very
definition of government waste and
here's the thing and this is where it
becomes what journalists do when they
want to bury the lead and what the
Republicans do what the right wing does
when it wants to shine the light on the
wrong things hey we're spending five
hundred thousand dollars to beautify a
park how dare we spent five hundred
thousand and and seven billion that the
end of the list how many billion forever
that's so much more than the rest of
everything on that list right because
right the duck penis thing which is a
purely it sounds funny but it's it's a
purely scientific base thing versus the
war machine and and the war machine is
so much more i is greater by magnitude
is it is way more money so final
question on this assuming the government
does spend probably more than what we
know it spends more than has but
assuming that there is some wasted
spending even outside of just the the
military stuff is there anything we can
do to stop it because it seems to me
that this thing has become so big that
no matter what we do we eliminate the
military from that women alike because i
think we're all agreed that we spend too
much on military right so beyond the
military okay even some of the other
stuff uh that if we had to tighten our
belt it seems like we just don't tighten
our belt like we just keep spending more
on everything that will pork barrel
spending exists because of lobbying you
know you have companies that will Lobby
to congress and congress will allocate a
single a significant amount of money
depending on the project to these
companies and they get paid they get to
do whatever project they want to do know
oftentimes it will be way straight the
only way that you can solve a problem
like that and we always go back to it
whenever we talk about this on the young
turks is limiting money in politics
getting rid of money in politics because
as long as that type of lobbying exists
politicians have an incentive to
allocate
money and it's problematic yeah if
government money could not go into
anything that was profit bearing so that
we had as strong a division between Wall
Street and government as we have between
church and government or at least claim
to have between church and government
then we might be on to something then we
might be able to save a great deal of
money you know if we weren't subsidizing
the oil companies if we weren't
subsidizing agribusiness if we weren't
subsidizing pharmaceutical companies if
we weren't subsidizing insurance
companies if we were in underwriting
banks and and profiteers then yeah we
could save some money in our budget and
I have to put the military in even
though we're all in agreement on it
because it needs to be said that I think
our government should not be in the
business of killing people and I think
that killing people should not be a
business